can both sides rise above
can both sides see beyond the political
problem at hand and admit that we have a
life preservation problem on our hands
matthew mcconaughey calls for change in
an emotional plea for stricter gun laws
after that texas shooting one great
thing about texans is that we pull up
our bootstraps very quickly and say well
let's get on with it it's a tragedy that
hits close to home for the texas native
who was raised in uvalde
my mom taught kindergarten less than a
mile from robb elementary
uvalde is where i learned responsible
gun ownership
on tuesday the actor took center stage
in the white house briefing room
delivering an impassioned speech
honoring the 19 kids and two adults who
died when an 18 year old gunman opened
fire at robb elementary due to the
exceptionally large exit wounds
of an ar-15 rifle
most of the bodies so mutilated
that only dna test
or green converse
could identify
now matthew is pleading for gun
regulations with all americans in mind
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
we need to raise the minimum age to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
2 21. these are reasonable practical
tactical
regulations
to our nation states communities schools
and homes
responsible gun owners
are fed up
with the second amendment being abused
and hijacked by some deranged
individuals
these regulations are not a step back
their step forward for civil society and
and the second amendment
politics aside matthew chokes up
detailing the dreams of several of the
fallen victims starting with his
encounter with two grieving parents
their ten-year-old daughter
alithea
she was one of the 19 children that were
killed her dream was to go to art school
in paris and one day share her art with
the world
now this particular drawing is a
it's a self-portrait
all right of a letha drawing
with her friend
in heaven
looking down on her drawing the very
same picture
her mother said of this drawing she said
you know we never really talked to her
about heaven before but somehow she knew
then matthew tells the story of a
nine-year-old victim with dreams of
being a marine biologist and a deep love
for nature mayday cared for the
environment so strongly that when the
city asked her mother if they could
release some balloons into the sky
in her memory her mom said oh no
they wouldn't want to litter
and the 52 year old actor can't hold
back his tears calling on wife camilla
alves to show heartbreaking evidence
camilla's got these shoes can you show
these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
these are the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
days after the devastating shooting
matthew and camilla paid their respects
at a memorial site dedicated to the
victims but there's one visit that
matthew says left a lasting impact the
dad of three stopped by the home of kids
who lost their parents
then there was a fairy tale love story a
teacher named irma and her husband joe
together they were the glue of the
family
both worked overtime to support
their four kids
therma was one of the teachers who was
gunned down in the classroom
joe
her husband
literally died of heartache
the very next day
when he had a heart attack
[Music]
they never got to paint the back of
their house
they never got to retire
and they never got to get that food
truck together
our hearts go out to all the families
involved matthew left on a high note
with hope for the future
we start
by making
the loss of these lives
matter
you